okay look at this nice and neat
organized Farm you guys isn't this
awesome
I love it
fantastic
[Music]
[Applause]
well come back everybody to Farming
Simulator 22 I'm an old guy gaming and
we are coming back starting this episode
with an end of the month update for July
uh this has been an incredibly busy
month
um with working contracts and um we've
made quite a bit of money
but we also had to borrow some more
money to get everything done so we're
gonna have to get that squared away I
just finished turning in the rest of the
silage Bales to finish up the hay
contract so everything that's on my
trailer and that you see in the field is
what's left over for the silage
uh we did a bunch of harvesting
contracts uh we did some canola and a
bunch of Wheat and oats and as a result
of that I got about a hundred straw
bales so we got a massive amount of
straw bales
uh doing all that and um we got a total
of about six hay bales of the large hay
bales from the hay contracts that wanted
hay instead of silich
and let's see what else we did a bunch
of cultivating contracts so made quite a
bit of money on that with our new
cultivator which is great
and
trying to think if there's anything else
in particular
to talk about
as far as you know the contracts go
so I I did have that same weird issue
where
if um I I you know I worked I did this
for many hours yesterday in real life
and I finally had to quit and I had to
go eat dinner and go to bed because it
was getting so late and so but I hadn't
fully picked up the straw off of the
wheat fields that I had harvested so
when I logged back in the next day
um the game had
well what would happen is it would it
would switch the swap the fields over to
cultivate it and not give me credit for
the quest so I had to log back in
three separate times and then quickly go
into the quests and and then turn them
in you know to get paid for them which I
eventually was able to do
but then it also made a bunch of the
straw disappear that I had already you
know was in the process of bailing so I
estimated
how many bales that I you know would
have otherwise gotten and and just gave
those to myself with the admin tool
um so yeah it came out to around 100
bales of straw which is huge I mean our
our part is it's not completely full but
it's
it's in good shape man we'll put it that
way good shape so
and let's see I don't think I did any
other types of contracts there weren't
any fertilizing or sewing or anything
like that in July
and yeah that's my that's pretty much it
I didn't bother saving the grain you
just don't get that much of it
it's more useful you know for saving for
your chickens but we have so much barley
now that I just went ahead and sold it
even though this is the worst time of
year to sell just about anything July is
a terrible month for selling but
otherwise you know we would have had to
take the small amount that we got and
start in the train station and pay
rental on that just to make like two
thousand dollars when the price is good
kind of thing it just wasn't worth it to
me to do that I I would have kept it
more for like I said the purposes of
feeding the chickens but we don't we're
in such good shape right now with that
that I just didn't want to mess with it
okay so anyway I think all of the
Silence from our fields are probably
yeah those are ready too so I'm gonna
have to get those loaded up I'll do that
off camera though it's going to take a
long time
um so let's throw these Bales in and
then we'll go back to field 71 pick up
the remaining Bales and then turn that
contract in and see where we end up with
our money
this is gonna you know we're probably
Gonna Fill This silage
storage thing back up again almost
completely full by the end of the year
and boy are we gonna make some cash man
off of that
I mean we we got sick full stacks off of
our hey
our own Fields that's just amazing
um you know plus I'm getting about
one and a half
to two
um ish for
each computer farmer hay cutting you
know too it depends
uh we don't get quite as much on the
first hay cutting but we tend it tends
to get better get better in terms of the
yield
as the year you know grows later I
haven't actually confirmed that for sure
but it kind of seems that way anyway
okay yeah so let's go get the rest of
these Bales oh where am I going I need
to go this way
totally
here yapping it you guys and not paying
attention to where I'm going yeah we
need to go this way
oh I I found a couple more um
Collectibles too
I actually found one of them a long time
ago and I keep forgetting to show you
guys where it's at let's grab that real
quick while I'm thinking about it if you
don't want to know where these are then
yeah don't watch
the next five minutes or so of the video
uh but anyway one of them
I think was somewhere around in here and
I I literally found this a long time ago
and I just
keep forgetting
to show you guys where it's at
I think it's somewhere over here anyway
uh maybe it's further down than this
actually
or it could be
over here
where am I getting all turned around
here
hmm
was it further down this way it's been
such a long time like I said I didn't
remember exactly oh here we go yeah
right here okay
so let's get whoops
all right
I'm having trouble getting to it here
[Music]
all right you found a cedar there are
four or more Cedars to be found awesome
okay and then I'll show you where the
other one is so
if any of you are averting your eyes
keep averting them for just a little bit
longer
some people like to know where these
things are and some don't you know
if I was
if I was watching me do this and I
didn't know where they were I wouldn't
want to know where they were I'd want to
find them myself so I would be averting
my eyes right now if it was me
uh anyway okay so let's go
towards
well here I'm not going to say anything
just follow me
we're gonna go this way and then we're
gonna go that way and then we're gonna
go up the hill and down the hill and
around the corner and under the bridge
and over the bridge and
yeah right
okay here is the other one that I just
found this one like yesterday
you found a water trailer there are four
more water trailers to be found nice
okay so that's two more collectibles
that we can add to our
our statistics
I'm I haven't actively looked for these
since that one episode that we did a
long long time ago where I was actively
looking for them I just you know I
stumble across them and
every once in a while and I figured oh
there they are I'll wait and show show
everybody on camera that wants to see it
okay so we are back now at field 71.
and we're going to pick up the rest of
these bales
so yeah we're not we're actually going
to get a trailer load and maybe a fourth
this time
but still I mean this is essentially
free silage
and we store it and wait till the price
is at its Max and then make a whole crap
ton of money off of it
okay so that takes care of the contract
Bales like I said I will pick up these
six stacks of Bales off camera and get
them in the storage before the next
episode
I'll do that later though
um so let's go back to the yard and
I did
go ahead and purchase
that lizard rake that that little front
rake and man I'll tell you what it is so
nice
it just makes bailing a breeze
um
really really enjoy enjoy that rake so
and I got the bigger one too rather than
the smaller one
and it seems to work a little bit better
than the smaller one too
it's just uh well here we might as well
Park this trailer
and then we'll take a look at our money
oh wait I gotta get I gotta get that
stupid uh
what you might call it Tedder in there
first
it's not a stupid Tedder it's a nice
Tedder
okay you could definitely move something
like this
by hand in real life maybe not pick it
up but you could easily push it or pull
it
so I'm just gonna
do that right now okay I think that's
in place whoops just
barreled right into my trailer there
knocked a couple teeth out
okay
that's good enough I know it's not all
the way back in there but
I'll have to do it'll have to do man
okay so let's see where we are
there's the rake right there that I
bought
I think it was like 25
000 or something like that
let's look at that
windrowers
oh thirty two thousand thirty two five
in fact okay yep so we purchased that
um all right now let's look at our money
turn this off
and see what we're doing here so if we
go oh yeah we need to turn this guy into
there's another 25 000 right there I'm
not gonna do these harvesting contracts
and as you can see there's uh oh
we just had a couple cultivating come
back up
you know I'll probably do those I mean
they're so easy to do
and I have you know I have my own
equipment for it so yeah I'll do this
I'll do them later just just know that
we're gonna add another eighteen hundred
dollars or so onto the top of everything
else that's happening okay so let's look
at the finances
um so that 32.5 of course is from buying
the The Rake uh we spent eighteen
thousand dollars in repairs because
we're just using our stuff so much
um
I didn't borrow any of the farmers
equipment for the hay I really should do
that for the biggest Fields it's it's
worth doing
um because
you know they don't they don't deduct
too much money off of that and I spend
more money repairing my own equipment
um if I use it so I really need to do
that but sometimes I just forget to or
whatever uh mysterious forty five
dollars for production costs there
um well actually you know what we're not
actually at the end of July are we this
is still July 1. oh right
um
okay well let's just let's just see
where we're at so
I sold just a small bit of bales from
the contracts we spent that much in fuel
ninety dollars
um we made
14 718 from Harvest income from just the
Grain in canola that we sold
and we made 164 000 431
or 341 uh from contract income which is
really good that's what we grossed of
course paid workers fifteen thousand
this miscellaneous is
what is that miscellaneous I don't know
what that's from I can't
I can't remember what this is for
um and then I had to like I said I had
to borrow a little bit more money early
on because I was like flat broke and I
needed to pay the workers so so first
thing we got to do is pay the bank off
so we owe the bank seventy thousand
dollars
um so let's do that now
and I want to pay them off right now so
I'm not paying interest for the next two
days okay so that leaves us with a
balance now of 53
798 dollars
okay so let's take a look at
and remember
um you know we purchased
we really if you think about it
we purchased that huge cultivator and
that rake
so if we had not have done that we would
have another 70 or 80 000 on top of this
um so that's really kind of the money
that we actually
you know have
um okay so anyway let's go let's go to
animals chickens are good cows are fine
for now
and let's look at the greenhouses
so this one is now we we now have to
switch this over oh no I guess I already
did switch it over to manure okay so
everything is switched over to manure
all the greenhouses are almost
completely chocked full with manure
we're no longer using solid fertilizer
and life is good uh we are gonna I am
gonna have to replenish the seeds in
here but we could probably get away with
waiting until
um August to do that so I'm gonna I'm
gonna wait till August to do that
all right let's see here
um
what else do we want to look at um yeah
let's look at the what we currently have
in storage
so 16
um eggs
13 000 almost butter five thousand
almost cheese
160 almost 170 000 lettuce we'll say 40
000 tomatoes and 77 5
000. uh on the strawberries so looking
good there plus all the hay that we have
in storage in fact
um this should show us that so yeah we
have now that remember this doesn't
count what's sitting on the ground that
I haven't put in the uh you know the the
barn or the storage thing yet so in
storage we have 590 000 liters of silage
uh we have 471 000 and change liters of
hay and 1.2 million
straw that's amazing uh what else this
is yeah this is the manure and the
slurring stuff so forth that we're
building up all right you guys now
I gotta show you something I I gotta
show you something
I'm tempted again I am seriously
seriously tempted again luck it at
what's for sale
a T9 New Holland what's this over here
oh that's just a forestry a forwarder
um a T9 New Holland
articulating axel
if it was maxed out
it would have almost 700 horsepower 692.
um but
in order for me to buy this now I would
have to take a significant loan out to
get it
it's just a beautiful beautiful tractor
but again I can't really justify this at
this point in time and here's why
because I have the man man truck and the
man truck can pretty much do all of the
heavy work uh which is is essentially
pulling that ginormous cultivator
and so it's I just I can't justify
getting this right now
um even though I really really would
like to do so look at that beautiful
tractor man it's just amazing
um but yeah I I can't I can't justify it
can I afford it yeah I can in the long
run but I just I don't know I would
really like to but it's more of a want
and not a need at this point I think I
mean we will eventually we are
eventually going to get a third tractor
and preferably
a big one
um because you know the more attractors
we have the more work that we can can
get done but again you know this is
really
for almost almost all intents and
purposes a third tractor and a 500 horse
one at that which we've already talked
about so I'm gonna let that one go as
much as as much as it sucks I think it's
the right move for us right here now I
mean I was tempted I really was thinking
I was thinking man
how can I justify getting that tractor
and I couldn't
this couldn't justify getting it so
anyway uh but the good news is we are
out of debt now
um and we have 53 000 on top of that
and um so
we really need to get a shed going over
here and I think that's what exactly
what we're going to do
um so let's um
yeah why don't we why don't we get why
don't we do that and then
we'll get everything situated
there's no reason not to do it right now
that I can think of okay so I need to
get all this stuff moved out of the way
first so let me get that done then I'll
bring you back we'll put a new shed in
and then start you know put our stuff
away and get our farm a little a little
more organized than what it currently is
okay I'll see you guys in a bit
all right guys we are back and I have
all the stuff moved out of the way spent
a little bit of time trying to decide
exactly what I wanted to do
for storage
and I think I have figured out figured
that out so uh what we're going to do is
we're going to go into
the build menu
and we're gonna put up two of these easy
sheds here I kind of wanted to do this
one but it's so doggone big
um there there's just no room for it
over in this yard here I wanted to I was
thinking about putting this one here but
it's it isn't gonna work
um the only place I really could put
this if I did put it anywhere it was is
maybe right over here
I don't want to put it over here because
I have plans you know future plans for
Productions in that area
um so I could put it here
maybe like right about in this General
vicinity
because
um
you know we have this room here and I
want to eventually kind of get up start
getting away from the weird irregular
Fields because it's just a pain in the
butt
to um you know to harvest that sort of
thing and have you know all of our
Fields nice rectangles and squares and
that sort of thing and so that that
would open up this area here for us to
put more buildings and stuff in the
future
and that's what we're gonna do over here
too so but I don't
I don't like the idea of the shed being
not in you know the main yard here first
of all
and secondly
uh I don't know if now is the right time
to to remove
this hay because this is making us money
right now so so I don't think we're
gonna do that I think what we're gonna
do is we're gonna take this easy shed
here
and we're gonna flip it around this way
put it in this spot here so what I want
to do is basically I just want to bump
it right up against the existing shed
then pull it out so it's not colliding
and go as far that way as we can go with
it so I think right about there is what
we want to do now let me turn
this way
I don't want it sticking out past this
shed here either so
we're basically looking at about right
there I think
because we can't go back any further
this way
so yeah let's do it
okay it's done
now the other thing I'd like to well
actually hold on before we do that
and we could hold it out a little bit
here let's sell it real quick while we
get the full money back
okay let's try that again
um
but I actually went right about there
now we're gonna we're gonna build
another one of these and the other one I
want over by the cow barn
and we're going to store
our equipment that we use to take care
of our animals in here
all right and the spot we're going to
put this is going to be right here
um I have
well
hmm
the other thing we could do is we could
we could instead put this over here
that would line it up with the cow barn
I think it would look better over here
okay hold on I gotta I have to think
about something here for a second
all right guys I'm back um it's like
really getting dark too
um but I think I figured out what I want
to do so I'm gonna go ahead and put
um this shed here and the reason the
thing that I was trying to figure out
uh just as an FYI was I'm planning on
moving the chicken coop
um this chicken coop over here and put
it and potentially put a second chicken
coop in later on down the road
um and I wanted to make sure there was
and I was planning on putting them in
this area so I just wanted to make sure
I was going to have room to do that and
I think I will
so uh what we're gonna do is
we're going to put this one here
and I'm gonna actually okay we can't go
any further to the right there because
the manure thingy
[Music]
um
and I can push it back this way
but I wonder if that's going to cause a
problem with the chickens so I think I'm
going to pull it back out this way a
little bit
and let's put it right there
okay
it's a done deal
we're gonna have to do a little bit of
landscaping action here
um but my goodness you know what let's
sleep and come back in the morning
and finish this out because yeah it's
just too dark so I will see you tomorrow
morning
okay so we have a nice bright sunny July
second morning
and um
I want to do something about this here
but I have to be careful of you know our
money
whoops
and uh yeah so basically yeah all this
left is to do some Landscaping to to
kind of fix things up a little bit I
just hope it doesn't cost us an arm and
a leg to do it so first of all
let's see if we can raise this up now
the idea here with the Crick is culverts
I have to assume we're putting culverts
in as we you know cover up the the Crick
running through here
um
so I don't know I there are some
there there's some mods that allow you
to do Bridges but I don't think there's
any bridges in the in the base game as
far as I know
uh but what we're going to want to do
here is we're going to want to raise up
the ground
and again I just have to watch my money
because it's going to get really
expensive so let's increase the size of
our our thingy here
and
raise this up
and like I said we'll just assume that
we have a culvert running underneath the
there for the water to flow
then what I think we want to do is we
want to level
now with here
and we kind of
messed up the road a little bit there
but not they're not too bad actually
okay that doesn't look too bad right
there let's
um
let's reduce the size of this
and um I think I want to go to softening
here
and we're gonna need to I'm gonna fix
this so let's go down another size
that seam right there because it's not
very realistic
that's going to be a bit of a bump
but I think we could live with it why
don't we do this
raise up a little more back this way too
and then we'll smooth
that down a little bit
that's not too bad I mean yeah there's
still a little tiny bit of a seam there
yeah
okay yeah that works for here
that should work for here okay and then
let's go over to
this area
we'll do here is
[Music]
I'm going to raise this up a little more
here
so it's a little more fragile
oh crap I just messed up my crops
um all right next time we do some
plowing I'll have to fix that uh let's
switch this over to the square
make it a little small oh I guess that's
all the smaller it's going to go
I think we want to go smoothie now
anyway
foreign
an angle getting up into there but
that's okay I don't think that's a
problem
kind of you know I I drive up here too
so let's smooth this
down a little more too so it's not quite
so intense
oops
um all right I think that'll probably be
okay
and yeah we're gonna store our animal
care equipment
in here
foreign
yeah I think that's fine uh you know
what we could do here is we could at
least add some
metal grass back until I can
fix it later
all right that's good enough
so there's something there
okay yeah I think that's good I think
that's uh
a good setup now again I would have held
this back further but we need to make
leave enough room for chickens
for two chicken coops potentially
um that will go this direction so we
would put the first one probably right
about here
and then the second one would go right
about here ish
and there's still you know enough room
to do that I guess I could have helped
that back a little further High
but I don't know
if I did have enough money to put this
in I don't know you know where it starts
to consider it overlapping
you know what we could do
just as an ex whoops I didn't mean to do
that well yeah just as an experiment
so we have 26 377 dollars I'm just gonna
add
um
a million dollars temporarily we're not
going to actually spend this money
okay
and then let's go
back over here for a second where are we
at
here
now if we go to animals and chickens
um
so I would probably start it right there
CES it says it's over oh nope okay I
think it's overlapping with this one
okay yeah that'll work all right let's
quickly sell these
good okay
that'll work
just what the doctor ordered
very cool okay now let's go back to here
and
and remove a million dollars
it's back to 25 788 what didn't we have
26 something I don't know whatever
positive and experiments okay so I think
we are in good shape so we got this all
leveled out over here
we still have a bit of a bump here but
it's actually not as bad as it was
before
we actually you know we could
here I'll tell you what I want to do
this let's go back into here for a
second
and back to landscaping and sculpting
I want to raise this up just a little
bit more more because it's such a
an abrupt
angle
make it a little more gradual coming
into here
softer than that
let's look at it
yeah that's okay
that's okay
all right cool so now we have
some more sheds to store stuff
so I think the first thing we're gonna
do is let's hop into here
and
I want to kind of do this based upon
frequency of use so we we generally only
use the curtain cider one one time a
year
when we're selling all of our stuff this
isn't a frequently used
Implement so that means I want to kind
of put this
way over off to the side here
all right that's some
it's pretty straight actually
I think
it's all the way
almost all the way back
now I put
put my header trailer over here
I don't I
don't really use this actually
I bought it you know because
Secrets underneath here
are collectibles
uh we've been living here forever and
I've never even looked uh anyway
um I bought this for our header but
I could generally just you know make my
way to wherever I need to go with it so
I'm almost wondering if we could just
sell the thing
uh how much would we get for it if we
sold it
um
I go here
that's what's in the sales
header trailer
uh I'm not that much money really
okay well what I'm gonna do then is
um you could definitely
grab this in real life and pull it
to where you needed it to go
um so
I'm gonna do that ish
it's such a pain in the butt to try and
drive
oh well okay I don't know if that would
happen in real life
and I'm gonna put this on the other side
of the curtain curtain side
this is where this will live
unless I decide to sell it at some point
I mean we're not gonna get that much
money I might as well just keep it
because you never know
I actually want it at some point
let's move the tongue over to the side
so that takes care of those things now
what we
frequently use is the water tank
and even the flatbed trailer we use that
quite a bit
so what I'm gonna do with those is I'm
going to put them
on the other end the the near ends
because they're going to be
where they're a lot more accessible for
us
yeah I really like this trailer
is a nice
piece of equipment
in fact it looks like it's probably
going to be too long for this shed
um
maybe what we'll do is this then
oh yep we're in the back
okay
yeah it does
it doesn't stick out a lot doesn't it
it's just really long
yeah let's just we're just gonna have to
go with that for now
that's you know partly why I wanted that
longer shed but
it's all right is what it is
at least the majority of it's undercover
now
and you know as some of you are maybe
all of you probably know you don't
actually have to put these things
undercover like you would in real life
but
you know it's just seems like the right
thing to do you know what I mean
so that's why we do it
okay
uh let's see what's next
uh we have the
we have the brantner and we have well
we're gonna take
we're definitely taking the silage
extractor over to the other Barn because
that's
for animal care so let's move that right
now
uh here's what actually here's what
we're gonna do with the truck so we're
going to hook up to the
cultivator
since we need the truck to run the
cultivator or operate it
and
hopefully we can park both of these in
the shed together and have enough room
to
to get the truck all the way in
it's going to be I don't know it's going
to be close we'll see
and we can put that right on the edge so
it's easily accessible
oh yeah we're good man
good
Okay so
this is where we'll park the truck and
the cultivator
a whole lot of room left there huh
it's for the most part Undercover
okay
that's looking good
okay and now what we're gonna do is
let's
let's move the combine over
we don't
uh use the combine real often but we do
usually
usually times a year
[Music]
a second
in the super camera it's actually
getting the
header it's not really getting the
header undercover though
you know honestly I like the idea of
moving the reefer over to this Bay let's
do it
a combine all the way on the end
now that actually leaves us
narrow spot there what could we
potentially put in there
something that we don't use very often
I don't really use the windrower in fact
we might never ever use the windrower
again
now that we have you know that fancy
schmancy new rake
so why don't we do this we do use the
the Tedder on occasion
but this was just
really need it
in fact I wonder if we should well I
don't want to sell it I want to have one
just in case and again there's no way
you could lift this in real life but you
could probably pick it up and and drag
it so we're just gonna do it this way
there we go okay
Pull It Forward just a little bit too
because like I said we do have to get to
it every once in a while okay good I
like that
that's pretty good setup there
now we should be able to put the combine
why am I wasting fuel
doesn't matter with me
okay we should be able to put the
combine in there now
it's about as far back as we can go
without hitting anything
that doesn't count
there we go all right I like it
I like it I like it a lot
looking good man looking good okay so
um let's see
this I haven't decided what to do with
this Russell mosh cultivator
the reason I'm hanging onto it is
because I could put a second tractor on
this to work if you know if we take a
whole bunch of cultivator contracts
what I might do though is I might pull
this Baler out of here and put it next
to the other baler
if it'll
fit though it's a that thing's pretty
big it's a pretty wide Baler I don't
yeah I could probably make them fit
Russell mosh
these we only use on occasion these we
only use on occasion and yes you could
very easily pull that in real life
um
why don't we do this
let's break that back this way a little
bit
put
and put all these in the back like so
okay
you'd have to have a pretty
pretty doggone strong back I think to
pull that thing in real life
I mean you could but yeah
let's use the tractor on that one
we got to be somewhat realistic here
okay so like I said I use these rollers
all the time every time we Harvest our
own hay we use them plus you know we use
them too when we
create new Fields so we want them to be
easily accessible
and so what we're going to do is I'm
going to put both of them in this Bay
here
okay that should be good for this
let's go grab the other one and put it
right next to it
I think we'll just store the brantner
out at the other Barn
well we might have to
we're gonna have to start a rake out
there too I don't know we'll see
and now this little Bay here like I said
will be the new parking spot for the
McCormick
we might be able to actually put the hay
rake
uh next to the field repair unit
here we go
yeah let's uh let's do that let's put
the hay rake
I think it'll fit it's kind of high
all right yeah so this will be the new
home for
The Rake
we actually
we could put even something in behind
there
I I've got the I don't really ever use
the front loader anymore
uh or these in fact we can sell those
long Forks I've never I used those once
and they made everything really unstable
it's this yeah we don't need this let's
sell it it's a nice idea but it makes
the palettes way too unstable
so the front loader attachment and the
forks we do want to keep that but I
don't think we can
I don't think we can fit that stuff
under here
um
we can we could fit the weights under
there
well actually can we put that under
let's just try and see what happens
yeah that works
oh very nice okay
perfect
two
honestly I'm not really too worried
about those weights I'm just gonna leave
them where they are
they're painted so
they get a little wet once in a while
not a big deal
all right let's see so I think we're
gonna move the telehandler
um over to the other barn and we still
have a lot of room at that other Barn
too and we're gonna also put the Brant
over there so let's let's take the
Brandon over there first
I'm also going to take the mixer and and
the straw Chopper out of the barn
and store them in here
foreign
put that there let's go get the chopper
in the mixer wagon bring that over
foreign
okay so
um
we want to bring in the telehandler over
here and
I might like I said I might move the
Baler into the
next to the other one and then we can
put the forklift back in the barn in its
original place where we used to park it
a long time ago
I don't really use the forklift very
much anymore either but I don't want to
get rid of it because it's
a pretty useful Implement to have
okay I'm just going to drop this off
here for the moment because we have to
go pick up the other attachments and
bring them over here too
all right there's the telehandler's new
home
it's looking good man coming together
uh let's see okay so the last two things
I think
that we want to do is I'm gonna I'll
just leave that open we might close it
in the winter
keep the cows warm
um
figure out where we're gonna put the
forklift and
um
what was the second thing I can't
remember now there was two more things I
wanted to do
hey excuse me oh ah move the Baler over
to the other one
this one's a little bit easier to get
get to
and you know we certainly could
look down here
especially since we
almost never used it anymore
since in fact we could even put this
down there too
yeah I think we'll leave the Russell
mosh just where right where it is that
that works
let's get this guy
I do know we have we have the flatbed
trailer there too but that thing I can't
use the tongue lock thing in the Middle
with it it's such a pain in the butt to
back up
that
is going to
keep that outside
don't worry too much about it
okay
that is now the new home for the
forklift if I could get out
it's a pretty good spot for it I think
and now we're gonna put the baler
over next to the other bather
I mean this isn't a bad spot for the
Baylor the problem though is that I have
a hard time
getting
off the tractor to hook it up with the
you know with the doors in the way like
here here it's not too bad but
if I get it a little further in there
then it can be a pain in the neck
and we use both of our balers very
frequently so it just kind of makes
sense to put them in
really easily accessible spot
that's tight but it works
nice
I could move the pottinger over just a
smidge too
but it's good the way it is
all right guys I think that's it I think
we have done a fantastic job if you
don't mind my saying so
um organizing our farm
looks much better now
much much much better
trailer can stay right where it is
I suppose what we could do is
we could pull the farm Tech in forward
and then back this one in afterwards
we wanted to
yeah what the heck let's do it
I was looking
I could have I could have sworn
that um
well you know what we're gonna do too
we're gonna back this in from the other
end because it's going to be easier
at some point I was looking on mod Hub
and I found this Elm Street barn but
with the working silo
but I couldn't find it again I was
looking all over for it and I couldn't
find it so I don't know if I was
imagining things or
did we not hook up our lines
okay
but I couldn't find it so yeah I'm not
sure
either I imagined it which is possible
or
the modern author took it off the mod
hub for some reason
because I was I was planning on
replacing this barn with that barn on
the working silo
but
work then I have I have another Silo
plan I want to eventually get my own
side load I mean you just you know we're
a farmer we gotta have our own saddle
right but the train starts the train
station works so well and it's so cheap
that it's just you know kind of made
sense oh you know what I have to kind of
lift this up to get it to
now there is this Silo that we're
looking at that doesn't actually work
there is an actual working version of it
but the problem is if I put it in I'd
have to put it next to that and then
we're blocking our
our roadway there so I don't think we'll
do that
I have two Poss other possibilities when
Silo time comes
um
but yeah we'll just we'll just wait on
that for now
we don't have a lot of grain and stuff
that we're storing at this point in time
so it still just makes sense for us to
stick with the train station for now
ideally we want to get the
tongue and everything inside
or at least as close as possible
how much space do we have
like none
okay that was like the absolute limit
that I could put it in there without
bumping into the other one but that
works I like it
that works
okay look at this nice and neat
organized Farm you guys isn't this
awesome
I love it
fantastic
uh all right so let's uh let's park the
New Holland
and we are finished with July
turn that off
let's go to July 3rd before I let you go
just so we can actually get to the end
of the month
okay welcome to July 3rd let's look and
see what the sales have
this is basically the same thing that we
have now except for it has its own
built-in
uh Bale thingama doodle
but it isn't any more capacity and
at this point that would just be a
luxury
that we don't really need
that would be a very nice
uh Implement to have though but yeah
for the price
definitely can't afford that right now
but it's tempting it is indeed tempting
okay so let's look at
um our Ledger again oh you know what
there I do have to do a couple more
things
wait a minute did I just take
oh I finished those off camera but I
never turn them in Okay cool so it gives
us a little bit more money
um we need to pay our worker for moving
pallets and also because I don't have a
square bale pickup I I use the auto load
feature on the flatbed trailer to pick
up the straw bales and the hay bales and
I'm not doing that for free so I'm
basically paying
uh workers to help me with that even
though in reality there's no way they
could lift up those Bales but we're just
gonna not get too serious about that so
we're gonna give them an additional 500
bucks 250 a piece
uh for helping us with that so that
means we need to take 3 700 out
to pay the workers
very good okay so now
this is our money at the end of July
we've already actually looked at this
earlier in this episode
um
sold buildings
oh did I put
I must have put a couple of things down
and then picked them back up really
quick and I may have done some of that
on camera some off camera because I was
messing with some stuff oh yeah it was
it was the chicken was it
I don't remember anyway I think that's
what that's from
um we've looked at most of this stuff
already so yeah that's um pause the
screen if you wanted it if you want to
study it but we've pretty much already
gone through this uh it's just that
we're two more days uh past so we are
now sitting on thirty thousand dollars
of Cold Hard Cash 237
um we have no uh debt
so yeah we don't own the bank anything
for now until until I take out another
load and we're in pretty good shape we
are in really good shape greenhouses are
good we are gonna need to get some seed
in the greenhouses I will probably do
that in August and also
uh I don't we yeah we won't Harvest our
our own hay until September and then
we'll do the farmer uh the computer
farmers in October their third day
cutting so August might be a fairly slow
month
um
and so because of that I probably will
not bring you back until
the end of August end of month update to
start the next episode unless of course
as always I have a reason to bring it
back before then all right guys thanks
for watching hope you enjoyed this
episode it was a fun episode uh we got
we got a lot of good stuff done it feels
good to have the farm all nice and neat
and tidy and organized I love it
um yeah so thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this episode please hit that
like button and subscribe to the channel
leave a comment shout out the video and
we will catch you in in the next episode
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]